Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
certainly one of the most famous dance
moves in big screen history Patrick
Swayze and Jennifer Grey and dirty
dancing which is turning 30 this year
and we have uncovered a lot that you
actually never knew about the film
[Music]
tons and tons of things were improv when
I'm teaching Jennifer and I'm getting
frustrated and I'm trying to try to get
her to be serious since she's laughing
her giggling the moment I run my hand
down her you know down her arm and that
really is me getting frustrated like Oh
would you just stop Patrick Swayze and
Jennifer Grey had a tense relationship
because of a bad experience they had two
years before starting together on Red
Dawn
despite that though the chemistry during
their screen test was undeniable I've
got control beyond belief in these risks
okay your fear will be going over what's
in the movie is exactly the truth that's
a scary lift you know and someone has
tapped us when you're just teetering at
your hips over over someone's head it's
a very scary thing to get up there and
have the courage to just do it with
abandon and let go but the lake was a
safe place to do it
Patrick's role was originally given to
Val Kilmer but he turned it down Sarah
Jessica Parker and Sharon Stone
reportedly tried to out for the part of
seventeen-year-old baby Jennifer had
five minutes during her audition to
prove she could play younger she nailed
it well I'm telling everybody my real
age you know twenty-seven and you know
nobody seems to care
[Music]
this iconic scene was actually just
Patrick and Jennifer messing around
before take the director like does so
much it ended up in the film and who
knew it Patrick tried to get this line
cut from the film cuz he didn't like it
nobody puts Baby in the film premiered
in 1987 but Jennifer almost missed it
because 12 days before she and then
boyfriend Matthew Broderick her Ferris
Bueller's Day Off co-star had gotten
into a car accident leaving two people
dead in Ireland I'm feeling so happy to
be here Patrick who passed away in 2009
from pancreatic cancer was reportedly
offered 6 million to do a sequel but
said no Jennifer went on and famously
had plastic surgery that changed her
look so much it nearly killed her career
her daughter Stella pointed out the
drastic change she said you know your
face looked really different in the
movie you looked really beautiful I said
yeah I said but the problem was I didn't
believe enough in myself well Jennifer
self-doubt didn't in there after the
movie's huge success she didn't dance
for more than 20 years but in 2010 she
finally competed and won Dancing with
the Stars I didn't even like dancing at
weddings because I was so self-conscious
that people would be disappointed in my
dancing all of a sudden I was realizing
why am I not dancing why am i letting
anything stand in my way of my joy I
think joy flows when there's dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh